Bác sĩ trụ quyền trụ quyền đào gạo, bác sĩ lỗi trụ tại các cơ sở nào tạo í qua
công lập sẽ được lỗi trọng theo dụ cầu như lực của người y tế thành phố Chí Minh.
Nếu lực lực trọng, bác sĩ lỗi trụ giữ kiến lực hỗ trợ một trọng phần trong học vi
nhưng không vượt quá một trăm trường đồng mỗi người.
Mỗi năm học, thời gian hỗ trợ được xa định theo thời gian đào gạo trụ tế
nhưng không vượt quá thời gian đào gạo theo Chí Minh đã được tất cả thật quyền phê rượt.
Theo kết quả khảo xác như cầu tại các bạn vệnh công lập trực trọng sở í tế thành phố Chí Minh.
Các đơn vị cần muốn trăm bác sĩ lỗi trụ giữ thoảng tổng kỷ phí hỗ trợ Chí Phi đào gạo mỗi năm.
Làm muốn mới tìm đồng.
Người được hỗ trợ phải cảm kết làm việc tổ chiều sống năm sau đó cao cho hợp không thực hiện lấy đủ cảm kết.
Người được hỗ trợ phải hoàn trạc kinh phí hỗ trợ tập quy định.